[Musique]
déjà mais de l'avis site ou manquant est
astucieux belle
c'est plus sérieux et a joué il de
vouloir revenir à un ami
[Musique]
fourrière comme axa serait pas we were
et moi bah tiens voilà c'est fini là il
d'ailleurs fatigue et toi non c'est bien
moi pourquoi de vente ont établi je
trouve fatigué penses tu des bases alors
tu sais oui autres enfants dont on dit
bonjour d'abord rire bonjour bonjour le
jeu est très difficile
tu vois ces bâtonnets que tu as devant
toi oui justement je me demande à quoi
ça sert sa partenaire par exemple et les
dames peuvent se faire les ongles et
puis on peut faire des brochettes ou ses
108 les mêmes un peu petit pour des
brochettes quand même sargue alors non
la petite brochette la double titre oui
oui la boutique est il faut faire
fabrice ce qu'il faut faire
oui avec ses 5 bâtonnets mais il faut
que ça me fait rire parce que c'est
amusant quand on soulève tous on en
tenant à un seul rigolo ça maintenant et
ça me va commencer tous en même temps
douce en même temps c'est pas possible
tu peux essayer un tout petit peu si tu
n'arrives pas je te montrerai monta
alors il faut il faut il faut creuser
tout ça en une tendance à me reprendre
alors soulève soûlard le torchon quel
torchon al torchon là où les bleues ya
le modèle tu vois on essaye de dire ça
alors attend d'abord soulève gens sous
les 20 et j'ai les autres ont cette
extraordinaire tu as regardé d'autres
qu'elle travaille un oui alors je n'en
tiens qu'un et vous soulevez en même
temps tout le reste des ford il a cette
affaire là je nomme quelqu'un est alors
celui là tu n'en tient pas compte
bah oui mais alors ça comment je vais
faire ça moi alors il s'est fait ça
comme ça et puis si tu dors là on passe
on mot-à-mot voilà et hop tu vas voir
gardien comme ça c'est à midi que alors
droit à un point à l'envers l'avantagé
sata ii s'est trouvé d'accord mais bon
on va passer au bota mots alors à paris
on ne tarit pas d'accord oui sans
problème
comment il a bien pu réussir cette
affaire-là demande lui de compliqué ça
bon j'arrive à brétigny voilà le mot à
mot je rappelle brièvement que nous
avons dans ce panier un certain nombre
de cartes sur lesquelles sont dessinés
des objets des animaux ou des choses et
qui forme une syllabe à partir de ses
syllabes
nous formons d'autres mots c'est assez
difficile hein c'est assez difficile
on y va oui on y va on y va je peux me
va jusqu'ici vous avez pratiquement
gagné à tour de rôle
je demande ce qui va se passer
aujourd'hui alors je renseigne at-on
alors rien prendrait 5 alors à l'optique
où la pl à coke
si tu veux si je veux c'est plutôt un
coq c'est en gros ça ce sont des oeufs
oignies c'est quoi ça ça fait voir ben
regarde certaines y c'est annie cette
indiscipline ça tu me direz que c'est
quoi une balle mal oui ça ah ça c'est
une chose très particulière vous savez
nous l'avions déjà vu l'autre jour c'est
le bout d'une canne à pêche c'est un
bois très attention cette ambition il s
cio n c'est un mot que nous ne
connaissions pas un sion et enfin 1 1 1
balawi le nombre oui le chiffre le
chiffre à elle a dit fabrice qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec tout ça attendez
pas à ce qu'il y avait s'il y avait un
âne oui j'aurais fait anne ni balle ou
lohan qui va louis meyer au hasard j'ai
trouvé ne vous fatiguez pas gentil un
formidable coque
1 ne se cherchait un coq un recompte
sais pas ce que c'est qu'un qu'aucun
débat alors un coquin voilà qu aucun bon
si tu veux je trouvais celui-là -
paribas c'est bien c'est bien ça alors
dis donc oui avec les trois mots qui
reste on peut pas faire grand chose
ben je vois pas prendre alors tu tires
d'autres mots je te convient bâtir
pire déjà un on va voir ce que ça
devient mal a encore un atout en inde
autre carte
encore une oui c'est difficile de pas ça
mais sans la finale aura un jeu je crois
que j'ai tout à non non non je me suis
trompé 10 pouces me suis non non non
c'est trop on fait attention piquant
bull
tu ne te donne des émotions et puis
quand bénévoles a alors continué fabrice
babin continu-continu sort une autre
caravane est encore une carte alors moi
je ne trouve rien pour l'instant
ah non ne vois-tu rien venir maintenant
est pas grand chose qu'est ce que tu as
trouvé ni animal en extension quatre
syllabes bien je me suis tapé fort j'ai
gagné a ni main et alors le scion dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
voilà bien jouer vlb très jolie a arrêté
le bout de la langue n'est pas prouvée
de la bête et le bout de la langue
oui on va tu regardes tu tombes il faut
être rapide à ce jeu après dans le
boîtier wi ali mation mais c'est par là
c'est bien joué bras pour ça c'est très
bien jouer un maximum ça bravo belbel
merci ça susciterait jeu maintenant on
va pas sur récompenses abri on va passer
avec moi je tiens qu'est-ce que tu as
gagné
je vais te donner un bouquet de fleurs
tu me fais plaisir
oui c'est gallas il est très gentil
merci me suis alors à gémir vraiment
femmes avec si peu clair je voudrais
vous signaler mes enfants que nous avons
reçu une lettre de la petite diane
bobille ont entre autres la petite diane
billon qui habitent les canourguais
c'est un salon de provence ça a la
chance à la [ __ ] dans le midi de la
france
c'est ce qu'on pourrait faire peut-être
pour lui faire plaisir est ce que vous
seriez d'accord si on lui envoyait le
disque de la chanson des 4èmes j'ai bien
mûri l'affairé fait oui pas le plus je
met sa lettre de côté d'accord voilà
bon ben maintenant fabrice guy tient à
nous de jouer le jeu arrive est bon
alors c'est aux ménages des pays bas
tout à l'heure à toute à leur belle
belle bon alors c'est un mot en huile
être un prix en huile est remise par par
un p un tat c'est fait voilà alors hein
2 3 4 5 6 la dernière lettre à dernière
est un y
un y oui oui c'est pas il plante c'est
pas un animal tu sais ce que c'est la
transporte un moyen moyen de 3,1 dans
les airs et aux non non surtout pas sur
la mer non sur un fleuve
non non non absolument
sur la route sur la wii sur la route oui
sur les sur la route sur la route sur la
route et dans les rues dans les avenues
dans les villes plutôt dans les villes
voiture un moyen de transport un moyen
de transport
oui ville et dans la périphérie une
lettre de l'afld une lettre alors je
vais te donner la quatrième
oui la 4e l'aide c'est un m ah bon m
à la 1 2 3 4 1 m 1 m 1 oui alors là ça
marche sur des rails c'est la marche en
dira oui on en voit plus beaucoup
oui alors tu permets une petite seconde
oui oui tu m'as 18 l'être oui il écrit
alors écoute moi j'ai bien une idée oui
mais c'est un mot de cette lettre celui
que je connais bon alors j'ai dû rentrer
je verrai un tramway un tramway talent
est barrée avec moi comment tu peux
écrire en huile être tramway ne l'a pas
bien là-bas tr à m
aux usa y tramway m
bah oui tramway voilà un tramway comme
ça la wii a tu vois que ça s'écrit comme
sainte rama mais ce n'est pas un mot
d'origine française un tramway mon
courroux smoothies on l'a enfin ça vient
de l'anglais ça s'écrit comme ça tu es
et à l w double à y croire
un tram ouais bah oui oui qu'est ce que
c'est que ça au moment là là là là là
pourquoi tu aurais pu me le dire quand
même la chance franchement 1 enfin il y
en a plus beaucoup en france en tout cas
à paris surtout y en a encore à
saint-etienne à marseille moi dis moi au
début tu sais comment il marchait les
tramways à vapeur
non il était tiré par dc vrai tramway
hippomobile oui c'est bon là il fallait
que les chevaux suivent bien les rails
bon bah maintenant écoutons le mieux
c'est d'aller voir bell bell alors
allons-y la fabrique
j'avais quoi
ces visites à côtoyer d'avoir des fleurs
mais petit abri très contente
bien sûr que je suis contente tu joues
avec moi le fils pru jeu suivant sls que
je te rappelle le g avec des notes je
remplace les syllabes qui manqueront
dans l'histoire que tu vas raconté qu tu
places sur la porte et ce qui fait une
petite chance pensait alors voila sinon
oui tu ne l'as pas l'air un peu endormi
endormi direction qu'il faudrait que je
te paye que tu me réveille n'a compris
ni le rire que j'ai dit que tu avais
l'air endormi alors non seulement on
veut te réveiller mais également toi et
tous ceux qui sont ici ce et c'est
parfait ainsi
c'est une chose on vibre à on marche en
chantant opa ope ce bac dont on se
balade dans ce cas là donc c'est
l'histoire de trois jeunes d'art trois
jeunes filles d'à soldats voilà qui sont
très gais ses soldats oui il manque très
gai ah ça c'est du un moment ils sont et
moi très gai c'est très difficile c'est
un adverbe un genre ils sont re re re re
es jolie le nom résolument réellement a
réellement rêver
manquant j'ai dit que j'avais les
rendormi c'était pas si probants écoute
ce n'est pas si simple 1 parlant alors
sur le chemin
wii passe devant la maison du roy et
qu'est-ce qu'ils aperçoivent une petite
fenêtre située à l'entresol insolent la
fille du roi elle porte du jeune robe on
dirait aujourd'hui une robe de gap
le gala une robe de gala de galeries
alors non jeunes soldats sont éblouis
par cette vision ses gracieuses
il en oublie la discipline discipline
certes mais sert maintenant ce qui veut
dire les notes récit la sole résolvent
la cie parfait ce qui peut se chanter à
al atassi on attend
[Musique]
sans voix mais deux des trois gènes
ce remanienent raison l'isle adam ou non
nous sommes aidés de gala
[Musique]
tu témoin locaux nos petits camarades
c'est formidable ça c'est la fête c'est
la fête c'est là on y arrive mais à vue
alors moi ça me plaît plus lieu j'arrive
rapide aux arts ea store suite à l'essai
vient vraiment inédit les petits soldats
allez les gars ça me sont déjà au pape à
vos amis les quatre majeurs s'est
désisté et g shock des choses mais comme
juni pas de mine war il faudra faire
attention les quatre amis réunis p4 ça
me rend heureux
paris c'est ma ville
le
[Applaudissements]
les caennais
à vouloir devenir un ami
comment s'échapper
[Musique]
c'est amusant